this is planning to be here awaiting of
course so to my first time in Toronto we
dated so you know you are very useful
spiring young people in all sorts of
different ways you must get that on your
social media how'd they say that oh I
love you for this reason I love you for
that reason it inspired me are you
getting inspired today by these young
people absolutely I always say the
reason why I keep coming back to be
doing the reason why I always want to be
a part of it is because they do you
never leave this event feeling anything
less than happy and positive and like
you've gained something or you either
feel really lazy because you're not
doing all the things that these kids are
doing but empower it empowers you to
want to want to do more and to want to
get involved and to want to spread more
love and kindness and just you know
because you see that these kids are
doing so many amazing things every
single day and that's how they got here
and to be a part of that is amazing so
yeah yeah and what's the response been
to why it's been lovely I'm very excited
that everyone likes the song so far and
we're still we're still we're still
going with it I just finished touring
for a little bit of time but know the
song it's actually really nice because
it's it's kind of about all of our
differences and embracing those
differences and when I I get to perform
it in front of as many people as I'm
going to perform in front of today I can
see that in front of me I can see the
different types of people that are in a
room but all brings so much love in one
place and it's just it definitely
embodies what the song is all about yeah
and where did where did it come from
like why did you have the idea that you
wanted to talk about having differences
and being able to still like hang with
people I think it was in the beginning I
wasn't think I wasn't going into writing
the song thinking I want to write a song
with a message in fact I think the song
kind of happened on its own and I was
like wow it's actually it's a very
simple message but it's very to the
point and it's very relatable to
everybody and especially at this time in
our world when we are you know and so I
think it was something that just kind of
not came afterwards but came as we were
creating it and it was just like it's so
nice when you can have a song that has a
little bit more meaning behind it
especially when it's you know fun to do
it
yeah now is it true that you don't like
to listen to your own music I think I've
said this once but I meant I don't love
listening to it like after it's out like
usually when it when it's out I don't
usually listen to the songs anymore
but no I I'm a big believer also in kind
of listening to your own music and
wanting to like your own music because I
do think you know you do have to sing
the songs for X many years you should
like the music you're making when you
hear yourself back are you ever critical
of yourself we just think yeah girl you
got it I did it depends sometimes
sometimes but then other times you know
I am like I am my biggest critic as far
as like Jays where I know that I you
know sound like I'm warmed up and you
know I've been working on it and you
know your voice gets stronger than where
you use it and so definitely when I'm on
tour I always feel like yeah you know
it's getting stronger but I'll be the
first person be like you suck so I mean
it's it's like it depends a good days
and bad days
that's a day a lot of really cool people
are walking around here Kelly Clarkson
today's show the TV she was like and I
never host anything so I must love y'all
I was like I love you did you hang with
her at all have you had I watched her
soundcheck yesterday and no I haven't I
haven't met her yet I'm very excited too
though because I've heard so many people
says she's as sweet a person as she is
an incredible talent yeah she's a cool
do you have a favorite Kelly Clarkson
son oh my gosh I remember my sisters and
I we were all on we would all compete in
dance competition and our first trio
together it was to walk away so that was
probably my favorite
and I remember competing in that
competition and the criticism that I got
from the judge afterwards was purple
girl forgot it because my costume was
purple and I forgot the steps so then I
mean you obviously rehearsing her
Sandhurst is here today and now I'll say
purple girl remembered and she's on
stage and she's singing after you or
some point I'm super excited to be
sharing the stage I have to do some of
the choreographer yeah I will I will
walk over it's gonna be so good so
you're constantly making new music you
must be getting inspired about lots of
things what are your top three songs
that you're actually listening to you're
right
Wow oh that's such a good question um oh
this is hard
I always makes bond if I play this of
like random songs it's hard for me to be
like I'm listening to one thing right
now I'm very into scissor right now
entire album is so good and Daniel Cesar
I'm never really not into Rihanna so I
love Rihanna but that's hard I don't
think I'm listening to three specific
songs I'm also listening to like a lot
of throwbacks like I've been listening
to Peggy Lee out of nowhere I've been
listening to I mean I always kind of
listen to the Beatles but no I mean I'm
constantly just sort of always
interested in the new and the old and
kind of finding a middle ground between
the two is that part of your process
like when you're listening to music and
you go oh I want to do something that's
kind of like that oh I want to do my own
spin on that or answer the question that
they're putting out in a song there are
definitely times where all hear a song
that's super old and go oh my gosh you'd
be so cool to make something new out of
that and that's how one of the songs on
my last album came to be I do love just
kind of going into studio and seeing
what happens on your own you know
without obviously any any like ideas in
your head prior to that but no there's
always times where you can you can make
something really creative out of out of
either old stuff or it's new stuff and
you take inspiration from it so what
sound you want to explore next you
mentioned just now like a hundred
different types of artists so maybe
scream oh maybe that's mine oh yeah yeah
you got a warm-up yeah that would be
awful for my vocal cords as far as me I
mean I'm kind of always exploring I
think your voice is an instrument and
just like a guitar can make many
different sounds I think your voice can
too and I think the more that I'm
writing this album and the more that I
am taking inspiration from all those
artists that I just named I'll be very
well I am very interested and excited
for everyone to hear what's next